chimpanzees are smart agile and crafty
and when they're hungry they can be
lethal as you're about to see here in
Tanzania Africa these apes are hunting
their next meal monkeys but colobus
monkeys are worthy adversaries able to
stand their ground against predatory
primates almost four times their size to
try and outwit their pursuers the
colobus lure the chimps higher and
higher into the trees where the smaller
lighter color must have an advantage
they can balance on branches that chimps
would break this male cowardice holds
his tail just barely out of a hunter
James reached giving the women and
children time to escape watching the
chimps chase the colobus is like
watching the action-adventure version of
a great chess match with stakes of life
and death
below a female chimp follows the action
no question who she's rooting for this
chimp is named Frodo he climbs and
climbs and makes a daring leap of faith
but the colobus isn't afraid of racking
up a little hang time himself after all
these little guys can make huge leaps
even as high as 50 feet into the air
then on the wrong move
acaba sleeps into the arms of death and
the victors whoop it up good
the young hunter displays his kill only
to have the dominant chimp confiscate
his prize
I guess these chimps are like the
National Football League no showboating
here especially when the tribe is hungry